hi I'm Eric Voss and welcome to new
rockstars rewatching breakdown series of
The Dark Knight trilogy starting with
Batman Begins directed by Chris Nolan
and written by Nolan and David s Goyer
with help from Jonah Nolan on this
channel we like to take deeper looks at
the big movies we love and re-examine
them to find hidden layers of meaning
and references and details that you
might have missed the first time around
we recently did this with the Marvel
movies and the next superior we're
digging up is Nolan's Batman
grave-robbing has never been so much fun
what subtle moves did the filmmakers
make to produce this complex take on the
Caped Crusader and change the way
superhero movies were made
let us rewatch Batman Begins
scene-by-scene to find all these little
gems okay so we open on a swarm of bats
and if you look closely and that swarm
the faint image of the Batman logo
there's already a lot going on here the
one Nolan is suggesting that this Batman
movie will embrace the heroes natural
origin the bat species in a way that
previous Batman incarnations overstepped
we're really gonna explore the
psychological thought process of how the
superhero Batman is a real product of
these winged animals that truly means
something to them also as we'll see in
this trilogy Nolan opens each film with
a hidden Batman logo among foreshadowing
elemental imagery and Batman Begins the
bat swarm teases Bruce overcoming his
fear of bats and later using it against
his enemies in the dark night the fiery
opening hints at the Joker's use of fire
and explosives and in the Dark Knight
Rises its breaking ice for the cracking
ice that Bane makes the condemned men
walk out upon and the way Bane breaks
Batman mentally and physically the
opening shot here takes us to the Wayne
family estate shot in the real-life
location of meant more towers the former
Rothschild estate in Buckinghamshire
England has been used in a lot of movies
here a young Bruce Wayne falls in a well
we get this upward looking shot of him
tumbling down into the darkness now over
the years there's been a lot of literary
analysis of these films and the whole
psychology of Batman and honestly a lot
of is just so nerdy grad students could
justify spending grant money I'm
rewatching Batman movies but I do agree
that the concepts of philosophers like
Carl Jung and Friedrich Nietzsche's
seemed to be influencing Noland in these
movies Jung even hits a shout out later
that I'll get to this image of Bruce
falling into the
ground cave does touch on a Jungian
archetype the journey into the
underworld in which heroes of myths and
stories tend to travel into caves or
poles are hell to reflect their inner
journey towards self-discovery here
Bruce's journey into the underworld the
Future Batcave hints at his
self-discovery of what motivates a fear
of bats from a childhood trauma fear is
the primary theme of Batman Begins and
all of the key players are defined by
their relationships with fear I'll come
back to this as it comes up now this is
all a nightmare that Bruce wakes up from
now as a man played by Christian Bale it
was an interesting casting choice at the
time Bale was best known as a child
actor turned method character actor
recently an American Psycho Nolan wanted
an actor who could truly evoke the split
personality of a secretly violent rich
dude and yeah Bale was no amateur at
that Bruce here is in a Tibetan prison
getting him fights with inmates now for
general audiences seen Batman's origin
in this eastern set he might have seen a
little jarring but it actually has its
basis in the source material Batman
issued 431 by James house Lee featured a
backstory of Batman's journey to to bed
where he undergoes ninja training and
long time DC Comics editor Denny O'Neill
made this issue part of the Batman
writers Bible so that way every new
Batman writer would consider this
particular backstory a part of the
official canon this along with Batman
Begins adaptation of this backstory kind
of annoyed fans of Doctor Strange from
the Marvel Comics you know since a rich
playboy getting mystical training in
Tibet was pretty much his origin
previously now in this prison Bruce
meets to card Liam Neeson whom we later
learn is actually Ra's al Ghul of the
League of Shadows in the comics Ra's al
Ghul has a long history in Batman's
rogues gallery always trying to balance
out the world with genocide via some
biological weapon and one of the few
Batman villains to deduce his true
identity both of which he does in this
movie the name Ra's al Ghul is Arabic
roughly translated into the demons head
he was inspired by fu-manchu's fiction
in the 60s actually if you were paying
attention
Liam's twin mustaches kind of give away
his true identity Nolan has said that
his Batman movies are really defined by
their villains and will sale the
director later echoes this opening
villain masquerade throughout the
trilogy both The Dark Knight and the
Dark Knight Rises also begin with the
villains hiding in play
site as they let their legendary
reputations speak for them and it was
the very first words exchanged between
Bruce and do cards are you so desperate
to fight criminals that you lock
yourself in to take them on one at a
time actually there were so I counted
six at first this seems like Bruce is
cocky and exaggerating this chaos or
maybe fighting himself along with his
enemies making it seven but actually
when you recount Bruce was right there
are seven of them the cards mistake here
could be foreshadowing his inevitable
loss to Bruce for his inability to see
the final threat and how he'll never
learn to - surroundings yeah I'm gonna
be doing that voice a lot in this series
do card tells Bruce to retrieve a rare
blue flower and meet him on a mountain
and when he arrives Ducard introduces
him to the man he believes is Ra's al
Ghul he's played by Ken Watanabe a whom
Noland later collaborated with again in
Inception and he is this exchange of
Bruce what are you seeking justice trail
by the way Watson I they said he just
made up a gibberish language they're
over here tomorrow I know but this idea
of asking a new recruit what are you
seeking from us comes from real-life
rituals of societies like the Freemasons
Masonic initiates are posed with the
question what do you seek and they
respond light for enlightenment and
wisdom but again Bruce's desire to turn
beer against those who prey upon the
fearful is an example of how the fear
theme is now literally stated in the
hero's declaration of purpose now notice
what the card does after kicking Bruce's
ass to do this leads to a flashback of
Bruce's bat trauma and his parents
murder which he blamed on his fear of
bats and this particular fearful memory
was triggered we now know from the
flower itself it produces a fear toxin
Ducard tucked it into Bruce's clothes so
that he would breathe it in basically
drugging him and forcing him to confront
his fear and foreshadowing his later
plan to use this flowers toxin on all of
Gotham but in this flashback we meet the
Alfred Pennyworth of this movie Mike
okay my go guy boy
Michael Caine starting with Batman
Begins Nolan and Kane have worked
together in every one of Nolan's movies
we also made Bruce's parents Thomas and
Martha Thomas is a wealthy industrialist
and a philanthropist who built this
public train to help unite Gotham now
even though Gotham has historically been
a metaphor for New York City Nolan based
it largely on the city of Chicago in its
L train this port here was shot in
downtown Chicago you can see the river
there and Wayne Tower is actually
Chicago's Board of Trade building the
Opera that the Wayne C is actually met
this stuffily by Arrigo Bhutto Batman's
classic origin was that his parents were
murdered outside his screening of Zorro
which we actually saw in Zack Snyder's
Batman V Superman dawn of Justice
Nolan changed it to work in more of this
bat imagery into Bruce's origin the
performers costumes are actually
designed to inspire that theatricality
that Bruce later uses in his life notice
how the performers are decorated with a
Batman style cowl and suspension cables
that's kind of a cruel show to take your
bat phobic child to but boy did hit
build character but one detail that
Nolan kept was the man who actually
killed the Wayne's in Tim Burton's
Batman the director retconned the
murderer to be Jack Napier who later
became that version of a Joker but here
it's Joe Chill the killer from the early
DC comics now chill was originally a
crime boss that Batman revealed his
identity to when seeking his revenge and
when chills grunts realized he was a guy
who essentially created the Batman
vigilante they turn on him sheíll comes
back in later comics including Frank
Miller's The Dark Knight Returns in
which Batman imagines street punks they
beats up our Joe Chill Miller's work was
one of the major comic influences on
Nolan's films Nolan also includes the
detail of Martha Wayne's pearls which
snap and scatter on the ground now this
is featured in several comic depictions
of the Wayne's death including the Dark
Knight Returns and another Miller Batman
comic Batman year one Zack Snyder also
made sure to include the pearls and VVS
- yo J now if you're listening the sad
music in a scene is the voice of a lone
choirboy
Batman Begins was composed in a
collaboration between Hans Zimmer and
James Newton Howard and in this moment
Zimmer had the boys sing in his words a
fairly pretty tune and then he gets
stuck it's like froze Arrested
Development this musical style reflects
the young Bruce Wayne's paralysis in
this moment now two other comic
influences were Batman along Halloween
and its sequel dark victory which center
around the ethically conflicted cops and
detectives of Gotham's finest including
Jim Gordon who we similarly see as a
young beat cop in this movie the creator
of those comics was Jeph Loeb who
actually shares a surname with
Commissioner Loeb in the year one comics
Loeb was more corrupt than he appears to
be in this movie though even though this
Loeb isn't in Falcone his pocket per se
he's certainly more focused on fighting
vigilantism than actual organized crime
and one last big influence I'll point
out is the movie Blade Runner Nolan's
screen the movie for his crew saying he
wanted to do Batman like this and you
could see the movie's iconic production
design reflected in the Gotham
underworld actually one of the actors
from Blade Runner was Rutger Hauer he
played the replicant Roy batty and he
delivered that famous tears and rain
monologue Nolan actually cast Hauer in
this movie he plays Wayne Enterprises
CEO William Earl we then jump back to
Bruce's training with the League of
Shadows his sparring with Ducard on the
fragile ice lake foreshadows a
punishment that Bane has someone trying
to carry out the legacy of the League of
Shadows forces upon the condemned
Gothamites in The Dark Knight Rises as
Bruce tries to warm himself Ducard tells
the mists of your chest arms will take
care of themselves this is another bit
of wisdom that actually applies the
later events Ducard plans to vaporize
the water mains in the heart of Gotham
and then let the appendages the water
lines take care of themselves also by
the way Nolan later said that this
advice has no medical basis he joked
that he could be responsible for Boy
Scouts everywhere freezing to death
during the scene decart alludes to his
wife who was taken from him we learned
this backstory in greater detail in the
Dark Knight Rises he was actually a
mercenary who fell in love with a
Warlord's daughter and she took his
place in that pit prison giving birth of
their daughter Talia al Ghul another
flashback shows why Bruce was never able
to get his vengeance Joe Chill was
released on parole and immediately
assassinated by a woman paid by Falcone
the crime boss that show was set to test
this happens while Chile's escorted out
mobbed by reporters in the second he
gets shot notice how a camera flashes
this image is an homage to the iconic
photograph that was taken the second
Jack Ruby shot the JFK assassination
doesn't make sense
Thomas Wayne was in many ways a
visionary kennedy-esque figure to Gotham
and before Ruby took the shot you
totally know John I was planted at Blue
Oswald away afterwards Rachel Dawes
played in this movie by Katie Holmes
takes Bruce for a drive through Gotham's
mean streets and she says this things
are worse than ever down here man do
people Gotham love saying that Bruce
confronts Falcone played by Tom
Wilkinson the judge he points out and
his bar is judge Faden that's the same
guy who just presided over the chill
trial and made it public so that show
could get shot Falcone is the first of
three villains in this movie and he
lectures Bruce on fear don't come down
here with the Arango trying to prove
something to yourself this is a world
you'll never understand and you always
fear but you don't understand I
mentioned before that the key players of
this movie are defined by how they use
fear and Falcone skis he uses it against
civilians to serve his own selfish goals
he profits off of people and Gotham
living in fear but Bruce Heath Falcone
ease advice and descends into the life
of a criminal which is what led him to D
card and as Bruce completes his training
do card and rouse all fake present Bruce
with this final challenge to take the
life of a criminal this leads to a moral
debate criminals mock society smoosh the
cards argument is based on the
philosophies of Friedrich Nietzsche that
I mentioned before
Nietzsche had a concept called the you
vermin or superior man that some men are
above the laws of civilized society and
possessed the natural right to take a
life this Huberman philosophy actually
inspired comic super heroes like
Superman and Batman as vigilantes who
operate outside the law but it also
inspired Hitler in the Nazis which is
why we kind of recognize this thinking
is evil
when Ducard vocalizes it they compare
Gotham City to Constantinople in Rome
which were two ancient cities that
eventually collapsed and ruin and that's
just step too far for Bruce so he brings
the place down a saves new car to the
craziest arm curl ever and then Alfred
flies in back to Gotham and as Bruce
brainstorms an elemental symbol to
chooses his moniker he returns to the
cave where inspiration strikes Bruce
embracing the storm of bats like this is
actually a real life therapy treatment
called exposure where the patient is
exposed to the source of their anxiety
to show them it won't harm them
meanwhile we meet dr. Jonathan crane aka
scarecrow played by Cillian Murphy his
backstory actually matches the comics as
an Arkham psychologist who conducts
experiments with fear they give him a
pretty good fit in a Batman story about
fear later in the movie he uses his fear
toxin to terrorize Falcone into an
incomprehensible mess which sets him
apart from this other villain remember
Falcone selfishly uses fear against
civilians crane selfishly uses fear
against criminals that gives crane a
false sense of superiority over Falcone
but yeah he's still using it for selfish
reasons meanwhile when Bruce returns to
Wayne Enterprise this cool little visual
detail here as the board of directors
discuss taking the company public and
that move hurting Thomas Wayne's legacy
in the background we can see the last
remnant of this altruism to Gotham the
Train and now bumbles along falling into
disrepair also that board member who
defends Wayne's legacy is Douglas
Frederick's played by British actor John
Nolan real-life uncle to the Nolan
brothers Bruce takes a job and Applied
Sciences under Lucius Fox played by
Morgan Freeman now Nolan actually
adjusted Fox from a corporate hotshot to
a desk ridden engineer though Fox does
end up taking over the operation by the
end of the movie by making Fox an
engineer Bruce now has a plausible
source for his weaponry in tech Nolan
actually put a lot of effort in the
ground a Batman in reality he wanted to
show each of the steps it would actually
take for a rich brat to end up dressing
up like a bat and beating up criminals
with a bunch of goofy gadgets the first
act of this movie laid the psychological
groundwork and now we learned the real
world military origins of all this tech
the suit is just body armor grappling
hook and utility belts just soldier
harnessing a gliding cape electro
current memory cloth in the Batmobile an
awesome tumbler armored vehicle built
for jumping gaps they even explain how
the mask and the cow are combined from
separate parts that Bruce and Alfred
have to self assemble from bulk orders
to avoid suspicion
this justifying of Batman's existence is
pretty impressive but it came at the
cost of universe building Nolan has said
that there's no way other DC
heroes like Superman or the flash or
Wonder Woman could even show up in this
world because just their appearance
would be way too fantastical by
comparison to Bruce's plausible
realistic journey to mass vigilantism so
if you're wondering why DC movies are
now trying to play catch-up with Marvel
rushing in their cinematic universes
into existence at the expense of quality
you have Chris Nolan's success to thank
but that's another video another example
of the real-world functionality notice
what Alfred says in the Batcave this
explains why the Wayne's would have a
secret lift shaft from the mansion down
to the caverns beneath also it
establishes the history of the Wayne's
public service like you can imagine a
young Thomas Wayne hearing about how his
grandfather participated in the
Underground Railroad and then dreaming
of saving the world with a railroad of
his own we catch up with Gordon played
by Gary Oldman as a detective partnered
with Arnold flats now flash comes from
the Frank Miller Batman comics he's a
crooked cop who hates Gordon for being
too much of a Boy Scout to actually beat
the crap out of each other and then
after forming alliance with Gordon
Batman makes his first move disrupting
the shipment of drugs and toxins at the
Gotham port is the first time Nolan
shows us him in action
though we don't really see him in action
the framing and the editing keeps Batman
hidden in the shadows Nolan said he
wanted to show Batman from the criminals
point of view so that he would be more
frightening and compared to crane and
Falcone the way Batman uses fear also
distinguishes him as a character he uses
fear and like crane II uses it on
criminals but rather than doing this for
selfish reasons like crane does his
motives are truly altruistic he gets
nothing out of it it's also just fun to
see Batman turn the tables here Falcone
begins this sequence with this line
don't burn yourself with these secrets
of scary people and then an even scarier
person shows up to freak the hell out of
him all of this makes Batman's
declaration so earned this is of course
a nod to Michael Keaton's Batman I'm
Batman and I feel like Nolan has to
include this line this movie is the
biggest statement of a new generation of
Batman since Tim Burton's film and then
Batman says this to the homeless man
this is a nice callback to Bruce giving
this guy his coat earlier but also Bruce
is realizing that he has come full
circle from the day he took off his coat
he shed that identity after Falcone
skies beat him up deciding to descend
into the underworld and now by catching
Falcone that decision has finally led to
a win the significance of this victory
for him is underlined by the fact that
Batman uses Falcone to create the first
bat-signal he publicly crucifies the
crime boss of Gotham to make sure that
the rest of Gotham can see it telling
them this is masharoun now and then
Batman checks in on Rachel and all I
really want to point out here for the
photos that he gives her to pressure
judge Faden to cooperating with the DA I
love that rather than Batman explaining
that this is a photo of Faden and a
woman of ill repute
Nolan just made sure the actress did her
best sexy face show don't tell when
Rachel looks to the newspaper article
that Falco knees arrest the reporters
names in the byline include Mary
McKenzie and Noelle Kellet those are
names of people who worked in the earth
department of the movie that leads to
Alfred lecturing Bruce about keeping up
his rich playboy reputation George Bush
Coase date movie stove's boy things are
not for sale
actually later that night Bruce does all
three of those things just at the same
time revealing how sloppy he is that
plain the persona during this dinner the
female guest who praises Batman is
played by actress Lucy Russell who also
played the female lead in Chris Nolan's
first film following actually the male
lead of that film
Jeremy Theobald cameos as the younger
Gotham Water Authority worker later on
next Batman interrogate slash and
Christian Bale found the Batman voice he
would be using from here on out it's
just cool to hear Batman cast himself as
a wrathful Old Testament God and yeah he
is the ultimate final judgement for
these sinners they finally have the fear
of God in them moving on to the Narrows
where people hang their laundry out to
dry even when it's raining but if you
look closely among the clothes on that
laundry line are a pair of Batman pajama
bottoms and we get a cameo by Jack
Gleeson a few years before he would go
on to play Joffrey Baratheon in Game of
Thrones this is essentially the last
time we felt bad for him has a character
upstairs Batman confronts crane and
stops his guys from torching the
building this actually parallels
Batman's first encounter with scarecrow
in the Batman
series the episode titled nothing to
fear there Batman also tries to stop an
arson attempt but he gets drugged by
cranes fear toxin which is what happens
here and while under the influence
Batman also briefly flashes back to his
parents murder that episode with
scarecrow was also the animated series
first flashback to Batman's past getting
beaten by crane is a pretty low moment
for Batman but here's the thing it's
still not rock bottom yet this won't
even be the first time in this movie he
gets his ass kicked and left for dead in
a fire in needing to be saved by Alfred
but that's another thing that Nolan's
movies do really well you're really mean
to the hero unlike other movies that
present The Dark Knight is nearly
invincible one who seems like he could
match the strength and agility of
Superman and swooping in and out of
trouble before things get too physical
this Batman takes a beating like we
later saw in the movie Logan Bruce's
suffering is a key component to his
character these movies really focus on
the human part of being a superhuman
later Bruce rallies and heads into the
Batcave accessed with this fund or bail
by the way those piano notes are de then
up and octave to another D and E and
then down to G and a and the reason I
bring that up is that when hans zimmer
composed the music for the Dark Knight
he created the Joker theme in a similar
way it's one note a D played
simultaneously with the next note up ad
sharp the note bends up on a scratchy
strum of an electric cello creating this
really unsettling distortion effect that
conveys the Joker's anarchy he turns to
me
why so serious then an Arkham Falcone
psychotic breakdown provides us with the
origin of the Scarecrow name witch crane
cycle analyzes this way
what Scarecrow patients suffering
delusional episodes often focus their
paranoia on an external tormentor
usually one conforming to Jungian
archetypes ah so that's the shout-out to
plus for Carl Jung that I mentioned
earlier now this is to explain the
shorthand here Jung theorized that the
human race shares a collective
unconscious made up of psychological
reactions to shared experiences like
birth and death and separation from
parents sexual maturity something I'm
still looking forward to Jungian
archetypes are recurring images and
figures that tend to have counterparts
in every culture like the shadow
archetype often takes the form of a
scarecrow which is a tool used by
farmers all over the world throughout
centuries and something that is innately
creepy that we project our fears onto
because it's basic function is to scare
now Batman rescues Rachel from crane and
as he defeats his second tier fear user
he does it by once again turning the
tables
he makes crane feel the same kind of
toxin induce fear that crane had been
drugging others with a literal taste of
the doctors own medicine it's
interesting how Nolen shows us the
feared toxins effect through the eyes of
the affected and Falcone and Rachel's
eyes the scarecrows mask transformed
into a rotting sack of worms and
Batman's perception added bats crawling
out of his mouth here cranes drugged
perception of Batman transforms him into
a leathery skin skull monster who creepy
he's got like black blood oozing out of
him so in the eyes of his enemy Batman
has finally transformed into a demon
coming full circle with the opéra demon
that inspired him as a boy in the
sequence Batman also comes full circle
full circle with his relationship with
his natural inspiration as the opening
shot foreshadowed Bruce went from
bearing bats to conquering that inner
demon hypothetically to exposing himself
to the fear practically and now
weaponizing the fear as a diversion
tactic against the cops
Batman's sonar triggered bat call is
another detail pulled directly from
Frank Miller's YearOne Konica Batman
uses the same tactic to escape a SWAT
team and when Batman blasts his way
through Arkham any viewers later
theorized that the Joker was
these inmates they do later escaped with
the help of Ra's al Ghul but this theory
was never confirmed the Joker's origin
from The Dark Knight was always meant to
remain a mystery and after the thrilling
tumbler chase back to the Batcave Bruce
returns to his birthday party and a
familiar face tells him this but is Ra's
al Ghul immortal Ducard reveals his true
identity as Ra's al Ghul by not into his
rumored immortality which is a reference
to the comics where Roz is over six
hundred years old thanks to the Lazarus
Pit it's a natural hot spring that
restores his health allowing him to
basically be immortal Bruce insults his
rich party guests who clear the room
which in a way is saving their lives
since it seems like Roz and his guys
would kill them all this is one of many
examples of Bruce making the hard
decision and letting his reputation
suffer in order to save lives this is
something he lets happen to Batman's
reputation at the end of The Dark Knight
and Roz explains that the fear toxin was
derived from the blue flower that they
gathered in Tibet this serves a dual
purpose of making Bruce feel implicated
in the plot and thus even more
responsible to stop it from happening
and providing yet another example of
justifying comic-book elements in the
real world harvesting a hallucinogen
from a flower could be inspired by the
plant salvia divinorum the active
ingredient in salvia is Salva Norum a
and it's considered to be the most
powerful naturally-occurring
hallucinogen though salvia certainly
isn't as dangerous as this stuff is in
the movie then Roz boasts this the
League of Shadows has been a checked
against human corruption for thousands
of years we sacked Rome loaded trade
ships with plague rats but London to the
ground basically Roz is taking credit
for the fall of the Roman Empire which
plunged the civilized world into the
dark ages and the Black Plague which
killed off nearly a fifth of the world's
population at the time and a 14th and
15th centuries and started the Great
Fire of London in 1666 which burned down
the homes of nearly 90% of that city's
inhabitants
yikes the depiction of the League of
Shadows in this movie is based on real
world conspiracy theories surrounding
organizations like the Illuminati which
people believe is a secret society that
controls global history through
terrorism and whatnot
it's pretty far-fetched in the real
world and yeah it's a little neat and
far-fetched in this movie too if you ask
me but then Bruce responds this way
Gotham isn't beyond shame give me more
time there are good people here this
debate is actually based on a debate
from the Old Testament between God and
Abraham over the fate of the cities
Sodom and Gomorrah God wanted to destroy
the cities for falling into extreme sin
but Abraham begged him to spare the city
saying that if he could find 50
righteous people living there the cities
would be worth saving Abraham haggled
God down to ten because back then God
was apparently just a grouch at a
farmers market
anyway this doesn't work because the
only righteous resident ends up being
Abraham's nephew lot and God ended up
destroying the city with fire and
brimstone a turn Lot's wife and assault
while this is happening we see the doors
of Arkham open and one of the escapees
is this guy Victor Zsasz you may
recognize him from earlier he was the
Falcone grunt that crane got declared
criminally insane this is actually a
villain for the more recent Batman
comics he's a sadistic serial killer who
carves a tally mark into his skin for
each one of his victims you can actually
see those tally marks on this guy's neck
Russ also reveals to Bruce that his
group was behind the economic depression
that led to Gotham's poverty and crime
problems and directly implicating
himself in the deaths of Bruce's parents
this sets up Bruce's motivation for the
final act a son avenging his father's
legacy but the conflict between Bruce
and Roz is bigger than that it's also a
battle of ideals because rods like the
other key players is also defined by how
he uses fear both he and Bruce see fear
as a weapon that can be used
altruistically to bring about a societal
good the key difference is that Bruce
weaponized as his fear against criminals
people who terrorize others meanwhile
Roz weaponized as his fear against
civilians the innocence whose values
just don't fit in with his narrow
definition of balance Roz and his men
ignite the vaporizer and spread the fear
toxin in the Narrows causing a
hallucinatory panic this leads to this
moment between scarecrow Rachel and
Joffrey Baratheon
but fear itself
sure it's a little goofy to see
scarecrow go out this way but it does
leave the door open for him to make
pretty crate cameos in the next two
movies and of course this line is a nod
to the famous adage popularized by
Franklin D Roosevelt during the American
Great Depression Batman fights Roz on
the runaway train aiming to stop the
vaporizer before it hits the water main
and Wayne Tower and spread all over
Gotham and as I said on a personal level
for Bruce this final battle is all about
his father
notice what Roz says here this line is a
direct call back to Thomas Wayne's final
words to Bruce as a kid and Bruce
responds by telling Roz that he has no
intention of stopping the train he had
Gordon used the tumbler to destroy the
rail line so looking at this from the
hero's journey perspective in order to
succeed and save the city Bruce has to
destroy the final memory of his father
the Gotham City trains so that he can
step out from his father's shadow and
define himself as his own man the Train
demolition and crashes the spectacle
that closes out this film which is a
noticeably downbeat ship from some of
the more explosive superhero movies that
Batman Begins was responding to that all
goes back to Nolan's decision to make
this Batman movie about fear
you could argue that the reason this
works so well in the mid-2000s was due
to the state of society at the time the
9/11 terrorist attacks left a powerful
legacy on the way we process media and
the way terror imagery could be used to
manipulate us perhaps the reason Nolan's
Batman was so resonant with audiences in
2005 is that it specifically triggered
our collective memories of terrorist
attacks after all what is Batman's
mission in Batman Begins if not a war on
terror you could even argue that Nolan's
emphasis on downward demolitions over
upward explosions throughout the series
could be a reflection of the media
imagery of terrorist attacks but I plan
to get to more of that stuff in my later
breakdowns but moving on as the dust
settles the newspaper article Bruce
Reid's was written by a reporter named
Julie Oh chip in T that is actually the
name of an assistant set decorator for
the film and after a green to some
distance with Rachel in the ashes of his
home we arrive at the movies final scene
Gordon finds the new bat-signal and he
worries about escalation in the kind of
theatrics that Batman might be inspiring
leading to the sexiest pink of this
whole movie take this guy armed robber a
double homicide got a taste for the
theatrical IQ waves a calling card
okay yeah when this movie first came out
there was no announced plans for a
sequel let alone Heath Ledger's upcoming
amazing performance in the role but
seeing this was still very very exciting
it's another little nod to the ending of
the comic Batman year one which yeah
also ends with Gordon on the rooftop
concerned about a new criminal on the
scene named the Joker also if you look
closely at the evidence bag here the
name of the person who recovered this
calling card is Jay care which is a
reference to Joe care Joker yeah one of
the Joker's most common aliases in the
comics this could suggest that the crime
scene cop was one of the Joker's guys
who had infiltrated the ranks or maybe
the Joker himself the Joker could have
been a guy working for Gotham City PD
who had a dark criminal side like Dexter
I don't know this is just a possible
origin for the character again we'll
never really know where he really came
from guys I cannot wait to talk more
about Heath Ledger's Joker and the Dark
Knight as a whole but for now I want to
leave you guys with the question since a
big part of Batman Begins agenda was
justifying Batman's existence as a
superhero how much do you think Batman
needs to be justified especially in the
years since as the Marvel Cinematic
Universe has proven characters powers
and abilities need less and less of an
explanation in retrospect the practical
descriptions of Batman's texts sometimes
came off is a little tedious to me in
this movie though I guess I didn't
really feel that way at the time anyway
I'm curious to know your thoughts in the
comments below so comment or tweet me
directly I da vas and if you'd like this
video hit that like button and share
this video around because we plan to
continue this breakdown series for the
Dark Knight and the Dark Knight Rises
and if you really dig this I'd love to
look back at some of Nolan's other work
like Inception interstellar the prestige
and of course subscribe sorta moogle
subscribe see you next time
[Music]